.
>> Laura: 3 OR 6.
WHATEVER.
"GUTFELD!."
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: HAPPY TUESDAY.
THE GREATEST TUESDAY IN THE
HISTORY OF TUESDAYS.
WHY?
I WOKE UP THIS MORNING TO FIND
OUT THE NEW SUPER MAN IS
BISEXUAL.
FINALLY.
AS POWERFUL AS A LOCOMOTIVE,
ABLE TO LEAP FROM WOMEN TO MEN
IN A SINGLE BOUND.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: I HAVE NOT BEEN THIS
EXCITED SINCE I LEARNED THE TRUE
IDENTITY OF THE YORK.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: THAT'S SCARY.
IT'S NOT REALLY THE ORIGINAL
SUPERMAN.
THIS JOHN KENT, SUPER MAN AND
LOIS LANE'S SON.
DAD SAID TIME TO BECOME A MAN
AND GOT CANCELLED FOR USING
GENDER STEREO TIMES AND BECAME
SUPER MAN AND HOOKS UP WITH
A YOUNG MALE JOURNALIST.
SUPER MAN IS BYE.
-- BI.
IT WAS A LONG TIME COMING.
IT WAS WORTH THE WAIT.
FOR THING IMPORTANT TO ME AS
A 10-YEAR-OLD READING COMIC
BOOKS WERE WHO THE CHARACTERS
WERE ATTRACTED TO.
I NEEDED TO KNOW WHO BATMAN WAS
SLEEPING WITH OTHER THAN ROBIN.
CALLING HIM THE BOY WONDER MADE
WE WONDER.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: HE COULD NOT BE SLIDING
DOWN THAT BAT POLE JUST FOR FUN.
I WANTED TO KNOW IF AQUA MAN WAS
INTO WATER SPORTS THUS THE
RUBBER SHEETS.
I HAVE NOT REACHED PUBERTY.
BUT IT PAINED ME TO THINK THEY
WERE TRAPPED IN TRADITIONAL
SEXUAL ROLES.
SPIDER MAN COULD NOT SWING BOTH
WAYS.
SAD.
EVER SINCE WAS A KID I SAW THEY
HAD MORE BOOTS, GLOVES AND MASKS
THAN A WEATHER SHOT IN THE WEST
VILLALG.
IT WAS LIKE BRIT HUME'S CLOSET.
WHO WERE THE SUPER HEROES LIKE
ME WITH ACNE AND SEXUALLY
CONFUSED.
IF THEY DON'T REFLECT MY
LIFESTYLE I CAN'T ENJOY IT.
EVERY MOVIE HAS TO HAVE SOMEONE
LIKE ME OR I REFUSE TO WATCH IT.
ASTRO-BOY WAS SHORT BUT LOOKED
GREAT IN RED BOOTS AND BLACK
SHORTS.
NO PANTS AND RED BOOTS.
I DESCRIBED KILLMEAD AT THE LAST
CHRISTMAS PARTY.
WHO GIVES A DAMN?
NO KID WANTS TO CARE ABOUT WHO
SUPER MAN IS KISSING.
THE GUY IS FASTER THAN
A LOCOMOTIVE AND CAN LEAP
BUILDINGS.
THAT PIQUED MY CURIOSITY MORE
THAN WHO HE HOOKED UP WITH?
KIDS WHO READ COMIC BOOKS DON'T
HAVE SEX UNTIL THEIR EARLY 30s.
WHY IS THIS BEING FORCED INTO
A MEDIUM WHERE IT'S NOT
NECESSARY.
IT'S LIKE GLUTTEN FREE CRUST AT
A PIE EATING CONTEST.
IT'S NOT FOR THE CONSUMERS.
IT'S THE COMPANIES DON'T WANT TO
BE CRITICIZED FOR THEIR PAST:
LACK OF DIVERSITY.
SOMETHING YOU NEVER HEAR ABOUT
IN THE NBA.
COMPANIES TRY TO PLEASE PEOPLE
WHO DON'T HAVE EVEN USE YOUR
PRODUCT.
YOU SEE THIS WITH THE NBA.
THEY ARE APPEALING TO A CROWD
WHO CAN'T TELL THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A JOCKSTRAP AND A SPORTS
BRA.
A MISTAKE I WILL NEVER MAKE
AGAIN.
IT WAS AWKWARD.
AT THE GYM NO LESS.
EVERYONE IS SO TERRIFIED BY THE
WOKE MOB THEY TURN ART INTO
PROPAGANDA.
THEY CREATE WOKE PRODUCTS TO
KEEP THEM SAFE FROM THE ONLINE
MOB.
I WONDER WHAT THE ANGRY WHITE
MALE HAS TO SAY.
>> NOTES ♪ ♪
>> ME IF I HAVE ZERO INTEREST IN
THE PERSONAL LIVES THE SUPER
HEROES OR COMIC BOOKS.
I AM OLD SCHOOL.
ADULTS SHOULD ACT LIKE ADULTS.
I HAVE TO GET TO WORK.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> Greg: THIS SETS A TRAP FOR
CRITICS.
IF YOU SAY THIS IS THE DUMBEST I
THINK SINCE SALAD YOU BECOME THE
TARGET.
SO NO ONE SAYS ANYTHING.
WE FOR A WORLD THAT INSISTS WE
HAVE TO CARE.
THEY DEMAND OUR OPINION.
IF WE DON'T GIVE IT, WE ARE PART
OF THE PROBLEM.
IMAGINE HOW SUPER MAN FEELS WHEN
HE IS TOLD ABOUT HIS CHARACTER
UPDATE.
>> OKAY.
SUPER MAN, AS YOUR AGENT, I
THINK YOU SHOULD KNOW NOBODY
WANTS A STRAIGHT WHITE MALE
SUPER HERO.
>> I CAN ONLY FIT ONE LETTER ON
THE LOGO.
>> OKAY.
WE HAD A WJ.
LET'S TALK ABOUT YOUR IDENTITY.
>> I HAVE A SECRET IDENTITY.
>> FAMILY LIFE?
>> MY DAD WAS A FARMER.
>> HE WASN'T MAGA?
>> HE DIED WHEN I WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOLED.
>> GOOD.
ARE YOU ATTRACTED TO MEN?
>> NO.
>> WOMEN?
>> YOU ARE ASEXUAL, PERFECT.
EVERYBODY WANTS AN ASEXUAL SUPER
HERO.
>> NO ONE SAYS THAT.
>> YOU ARE NOT ATTRACTED TO
ANYONE.
I AM A DIFFERENT SPECIES.
>> FANTASTIC, YOU ARE AN
IMMIGRANT.
>> I AM AN ALIEN.
>> EASY WITH THE A -WORD.
>> I AM SUPER MAN.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: THE DIVIDE BETWEEN YOUR
PUBLIC STANCE AND HOW YOU FEEL.
PUBLICLY YOU CAN SAY SUPER MAN
YOU GO, BOY.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT A BUNCH OF
[BLEEP] IT IS.
TURN SUPER MAN INTO POLITICAL
THEATER.
WHEN YOU EXPECT ME TO CARE, I
WILL CRAP ALL OVER YOU EVEN IF
YOU DIDN'T PAY ME FIRST.
IN A FAIR WORLD IT IS NOT OF OUR
BUSINESS.
I DON'T NEED TO KNOW WHAT YOU DO
SEXUALLY ANYMORE THAN YOU NEED
TO KNOW WHAT TURNS ME ON AND WHY
IT REQUIRES A SOCK FULL OF
BATTERIES.
WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST.
FOUGHT FOR OUR FREEDOM AND
LOOKED DAMN GOOD.
ROB SMITH!
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: HIS VOICE CRACKS MORE
THAN THE LIBERTY BELL, COMEDIAN,
JOE MACHI.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: SHE IS A LIKE GERBIL.
KAT TIMPF.
>> Greg: AND WHEN GOLDEN CORAL
SEES HIM COMING THEY SURRENDER.
MY MASSIVE SIDE KICK TYRUS.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: FOR NO PARTICULAR
REASON, YOU ARE A GAY SUPER
HERO.
>> I GUESS SO, YES.
>> Greg: YOU FOUGHT FOR OUR
COUNTRY AND YOU ARE GAY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
PROGRESS OR TMI?
>> AS A PRACTICING HOMOSEXUAL I
AM GLAD YOU CAME TO ME FIRST.
FIRST OF ALL I HATE THIS
RECONING OF ICONIC CHARACTERS WE
HAVE.
MAKING THEM BISEXUAL.
>> Greg: WHAT IS THAT?
>> IT MEANS THEY ARE MAKING
SOMETHING NEW OUT OF WHAT WAS
THERE BEFORE.
INSTEAD OF HAVING SOMETHING
COMPLETELY NEW.
AS A GAY GUY IT WOULD BE COOL TO
HAVE AN ORIGINAL GAY SUPER HERO
AND I SAY THE SAME CONVERSATION
ABOUT MAKING JAMES BOND BLACK.
I WANT A COOL SUPER SPY THAT IS
BLACK THAT IS COMPLETELY KNEW.
>> Greg: SEPARATE BUT SCHEDULE.
-- EQUAL.
IT MAKES SENSE.
JUST COME UP WITH SOMETHING NEW.
>> THEY COULD MAKE A COMIC BOOK
ABOUT YOU.
YOU WOULD BE PERFECT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: JOE, I MAY BE JUMPING
TO CONCLUSIONS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> HE'S ALSO HANDSOME.
>> Greg: WERE YOU INTERESTED IN
SUPER MAN'S SEXUALITY WHEN YOU
WERE A CHILD?
>> I DON'T THINK ANYONE WAS
INTERESTED IN SEXUALITY AFTER
SEEING MARLON BRANDO IN THAT
SKIN TIGHT SUIT.
I WAS TO BE LIKE SUPER MAN
BECAUSE HE COULD DO A LOT OF
THINGS A DORKY NERD COULD NOT
DO.
HE COULD BEAT UP A JERK OR STOP
A NUCLEAR WAR BY THROWING
MISSILES IN THE SUN.
HOW COULD THE PEOPLE OF KRYPTON
DO NOTHING WHILE THEIR PLANET
FELL APART?
WITH THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
THAT SEEMS QUITE POSSIBLE.
>> Greg: A JAB ON BIDEN.
MAYBE YOU ARE SUPER MAN.
>> CLEARLY NOT.
>> Greg: WOW!
I FELT A TINGLE THERE.
KAT, WHERE ARE YOU ON THIS?
>> I THINK IT'S FINE.
YES, THAT'S HOW I FEEL WITH
ANYBODY'S SEXUALITY.
I THINK IT'S FINE.
THAT WILL PROBABLY BE THE REAL
PROGRESS.
I AM GAY, I AM BI.
PEOPLE WILL SAY COOL.
IT'S NOT A HUGE DEAL.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WANTS TO
DEFINED BY THE SEX STUFF THEY
DO.
>> Greg: NO.
>> THE SEX STUFF THEY DO?
>> OR WANT TO DO OR THEY HAVE
DONE.
NOBODY WANTS TO BE DEFINED BY
THAT.
>> Greg: I AM DEFINED BY THE
THINGS I HAVE NOT DONE WHICH IS
NOT A LOT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: THE ONE THING I MIGHT
BE DOING THAT IS WRONGS
ATTRIBUTING THE WRONG AUDIENCE
FOR THIS PRODUCT.
THIS COMIC BOOK IS NOT FOR KIDS.
IT'S FOR DORKY WEIRDOS?
SORRY JOE?
>> I HAVE BEEN DEFINED BY MY
SEXUALITY.
I HAVE BEEN CALLED A CHUBBY
PANDA.
I PREFER TO BE KNOWN FOR OTHER
THINGS.
TO HIS POINT, I READ COMIC BOOKS
MY HOLE LIFE AND STILL COLLECT
THEM.
I NEVER CARED WHAT A SUPER HERO
DID BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
I FEEL IT CHEAPENS THE MESSAGE.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO SUPPORT THE
GAY COMMUNITY AND GAY MEN AND
YOU WANT TO MAKE A GAY SUPER
HERO HAVE THE DECENCY TO GIVE US
A GREAT BACK STORY.
HAVE US SEE THE STRUGGLE AND SEE
HIM SURVIVE AND THEN PEOPLE WILL
BE INSPIRED BY HIM.
IT WON'T BE HIM.
IT WILL BE ALL GUYS.
HE JUST HAPPENS TO BE GUY.
THEY HAVE SUPER POWERS.
THAT'S WHAT GET US TO FALL IN
LOVE WITH SUPER HEROES.
IT'S THEIR STRUGGLE TO BECOME
THESE AMAZING THINGS.
I APPRECIATE THE FACT HE IS THE
CHILD OF SUPER MAN AND LOIS,
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT IDEA.
YOU CAN DO BETTER.
YOU CAN DO BETTER WITH COMIC
BOOKS.
THIS SHOULD NOT BE THE ISSUE.
I HAVE BEEN IN ENTERTAINMENT
A LONG TIME.
WHEN I HAVE WITH WWE AND THE
GUYS I WORKED WITH, THEY ARE GAY
AND THEIR BIGGEST THING IS THEY
HATE TO BE IDENTIFIED BY JUST
THEIR SEXUALITY.
I AM A GREATEST WRESTLER.
WHOM I IN THE BEDROOM WITH
DOESN'T MATTER.
IF YOU ASK ME I WILL TELL YOU.
EVERY TIME I WRESTLE I DON'T
WANT TO HEAR THAT'S A GREAT GAY
WRESTLER.
>> Greg: ARE THERE A LOT OF GAY
WRESTLERS?
>> IT'S WRESTLING.
EVERYBODY IS GAY SOMETIMES.
>> YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
I DO THE PODCAST.
TALKING ABOUT BIDEN'S FAILURE
AND KAMALA HARRIS.
THE GAY STUFF DOESN'T COME OUT
UNTIL SITUATIONS LIKE THIS.
I AM NOT DEFINED BY THAT.
I DON'T THINK TO YOUR POINT THA